[Music]
with that thank you all so much for
taking the time out of your day to join
us today and welcome to the data science
hangout if we have never met before I'm
Rachel Dempsey I'm the host of our
hangout here and I lead our customer
marketing at
if it's your first time joining this is
our open space to chat about data
Science Leadership questions you're
facing and getting to hear about what's
going on in the world of data across all
different Industries and so we're here
every Thursday at the same time same
place so if you're watching this
recording on YouTube later and maybe
want to join us live there'll be a link
below where you can add it to your
calendar at the Hangouts we're all
dedicated to to making this a welcoming
environment for everyone we love to hear
from everybody no matter your years of
experience your titles your industry or
even the languages that you work in it's
totally okay for you to just listen in
here maybe it's during your lunch break
or out for a walk but there's always
three ways you can jump in and ask
questions or provide your own
perspective on topics too so you can
jump in by raising your hand on
zoom and I'll keep an eye out for that
you can put questions in Zoom chat uh
and just put a little star next to it if
it's something you want me to read out
loud instead otherwise I'll just calling
you to jump in the
conversation and then lastly we have a
slider link where you can ask questions
anonymously too with that I am so
excited to be joined by a few different
co-hosts this week so we're doing things
a little bit differently we have three
people joining us today from Biogen um
so I'm so happy to be joined by Dan
Danielle and Anuja from the technology
strategy and Innovation group at
Biogen and I uh I first connected with
Dan think on LinkedIn when he reached
out about a data competition they were
running and so I'm so excited to be able
to learn a bit more about that today um
and I thought we could just start with
some introductions on your side I don't
know if Dan you want to get started
maybe share a little bit about your role
and also something you like to do
outside of work oh boy right on the spot
okay no great my name is Dan B uh I work
at Biogen which is a biopharmaceutical
company based in Cambridge but we're
worldwide I've been a Biogen for 12
years which makes me sound old um I do
things change a lot over here and they
just recently changed but I do a lot of
Technology strategy I do a lot of data
strategy I really think about our
clinical trial data um and how we can
best leverage that both for our business
but also just for you Humanity for for
us to develop better medicine for us to
understand disease
better so that's what I try to do and
maybe I'll hand it over to Anuja sure hi
everyone my name is Anuja dasas I also
work at Biogen have been there about two
and a half years maybe that makes me
sound young I'm not
sure but I um have worked over the past
few years on a variety of projects
primarily within technology and I
contribute typically from a project
management and strategy contribution
point of view but I've also been able to
delve into the technical aspects a
little bit my my favorite part of my job
so far is kind of bringing people
together who speak different languages
and have a variety of skill sets to work
towards the same kind of end Target and
solution and so the data Jam was like a
large scale embodiment of that and it
was fabulous to see so I'm very excited
to talk about that today and I sorry
just realized I didn't say what I do
outside of work because I just I live
here um I'm a I'm an avid disc golfer so
I don't know if anyone plays disc golf
on the phone but I I I'm an avid dis
golfer and I also like to bake a lot
sorry so I my my pandemic hobby was to
learn how to knit and so I've been
trying to do that like knit myself some
sweaters which is in I'm in my grandma
mode but that's what I like to do
outside of work I love it I might have
to ask you about that because our book
club was thinking about doing that as an
activity oh yeah yeah um Danielle do you
want to go next yeah hi everyone I'm
Danielle cluer um so I've been at byen
for almost 11 and a half years um so
I've had many different roles um at byen
but my most recent one is um uh decision
analytics specifically portfolio and
program modeling analytics to dve
decision-making um strategic decision-
making um and something I like to do
outside of work was I love obviously
love to travel specifically eat
different foods but more recently I did
take up um learning how to golf love it
are you all are all three of you in the
Boston area yes okay
nice um well I know we kind of alluded
to the data Jam a little bit so I
thought it might be helpful in the
beginning to just kind of share a little
bit about the story of how that came to
be and maybe what the data Jam is yeah
Danielle do you want to give it a shot
so the whole re the whole so we have a
couple different community of practices
at Biogen one of them that an and I lead
is the um data and analytics and really
the whole goal was just to get people
across byen that are passionate about
data and analytics together um just to
learn sort of the different ways that we
work across the different groups find
areas of opportunity and collaboration
as well as Network um and really the way
the data Jam came about is things have
been
pretty uh uh uh has been pretty
interesting at work and so we wanted to
try to find a way to have a little bit
of fun try to get people together I
think an had mentioned she loves getting
people together so do I so we decided
why not try to throw together a data jam
and something that we thought would just
be something small and fun turned out to
be something actually very big and
really show the passion that uh people
at Bon has for data I know Dana nja if
you want to add on to that that was
pretty good from my perspective I mean I
think you know anything that's
successful I think always happens
something like this Danielle comes to me
Danielle and Anuja come to me in one
meeting and say hey I think we should
like do like a data competition like all
right sure let's uh let's put that
together let's see what that looks like
and you know the day you you send it out
like I was hoping I was hoping myself 30
people would show would show up I
thought if we had 30 people we'd have
like what you put like five people on a
team you have like six teams you have a
good competition with six teams uh I
think in the first hour 50 people signed
up and then we just kind of went into
panic mode of how we're going to
organize this which we could also talk
about because there's a lot there um but
really you know I think it it starts on
something small and then you we just had
such a great team together to be able to
put something like this together just it
really worked out well so I I think a
lot of people like have ideas for things
like this or just like ideas in general
that they'll bring to meetings but you
all actually made it happen how did you
go from just an idea for something to
making it this real life
event at nja you want to take that yeah
I can take that um I think actually
executing to the point of like send
getting a data set and sending out um a
form for signups was fairly
straightforward we had a couple of ideas
of data sets that we could use um and so
we landed on one and then just kind of
decided to go for it we had enough
information to execute and we we sent it
out uh where the challenge came in was
when we saw the rate of signups because
people we realized we knew on some level
but we really saw that people love data
and are passionate about it and want to
work um on a hackathon of sorts or data
Jam of sorts so I will say that we it
got a little challenging when we hit you
know 200 to 250 because our previous
kind of plan for how we were going to
run it um wasn't really going to work
anymore given the numbers and so there
was a lot of kind of planning on the fly
so when we saw how many people there
were we kind of decided let's do two
rounds instead of one and so it was part
of the excitement but it it also was
part of the challenge of figuring out
how to accommodate um the growing number
of participants so yeah I think part of
it too was that we actually had support
from our leadership to actually go forth
and do this and that helped a lot um I
think part of it too was the fact that
there has been a lot of of eyes just on
data in general for many different
reasons so I think that also helped but
a lot of it too is us just trying to
figure out how to even pull it off and
then we
did to be completely honest and you know
I might clarify what Danielle says
because it's not like we were given a
task to go run a data Jam like at some
point we just had to make a decision
like like Rachel says there are ideas
all the time right how do you like do it
there's a little bit of a leap of faith
there I think you just kind of you know
what's the worst that can happen is no
one signs up and we just go back to our
day jobs um what's the best thing that
can happen is you know whole bunch of
people sign up so there is like just a
little bit of I know boldness from from
this team to be able say all right let's
do it let's get give it a shot and see
what happens I think a lot of it too we
just asked like it was like there's no
there's no downside they could you know
expect you know and so I think a lot of
it was just we just asked and it seemed
like we were able to get a lot of things
a lot of yeses actually
that's great i' I've been thinking about
doing something kind of like that at
posit so that we could like mix people
across all different teams like customer
success and some of the open source
package developers to kind of work on a
common problem together um and it's just
been like an idea floating around in my
head so I was just curious how you went
and and made it actually happen um but I
was wondering for the the teams were
people like mix across different parts
of the company or could people be it
could be a group of whoever wanted to
join together we decided to randomize it
and so we had people sign up and part of
the sign up was asking what their kind
of capabilities were so is it that
they've never really coded before are
they like experts or gurus do they fall
fall somewhere in the middle um so we we
kind of defined four different levels uh
of Competency and and had people
describe or kind of self-identify you
within one of those four and then what
we tried to do is when we did randomize
teams we tried to kind of spread the
capabilities out honestly most people
fell in the middle um but we didn't want
to put all the experts together but also
didn't want to have a team that was all
novices and so we the data Jam of course
it was about data but another kind of
primary element was for people to meet
each other and so we didn't want people
to just stay within their team so this
was an opportunity to network outside as
well yeah it was uh it was kind of wild
the teams because we don't know any of
the people you know but bient a big
company um but the teams end up kind of
wild you know multiple time zones people
in like bu no Aries and China and
Switzerland and us and uh you know they
gave them like three weeks to go analyze
some data they don't know each other
they're working wildly different
departments you know some in
manufacturing some in sales you know
some in R&D um so it like you're saying
Rachel to a big part is getting those
people force them into something and I
feel like you get a lot of benefit when
people are forced to problem solve
together because that like it creates
like a little bit of I don't know a
little bit of conflict and when you get
that conflict then you get people's
different opinions coming out and the
different viewpoints then you build on
something together so um I think that
part was really wildly successful and
people had a good time meeting people
across the or yeah thank you Alan I see
you asked a question in the chat here do
you want to jump in yeah sure hey
everybody um I think Dan was kind of
just speaking to to part of the question
noting that folks had sort of several
weeks to put something together and they
were kind of all over the place um I'd
really like to know more about like what
did they what did they make like and how
much structure did you give them to lead
into that like was this a an internal
and external data set and did you give
them a bunch of specific problems or did
you say hey here's a pile of data like
find something fun and interesting and
and make something and I just I'm
curious about the array of things that
they made and what the like sharing with
a great big set of like 200 people
sharing that back out at scale is also
really challenging so you know how did
that um how did the sort of conducting
of the rest of the thing kind of unfold
um there's a whole bunch there whatever
is kind of interesting to speak to um
I'd love to hear about thanks maybe
Danielle yeah so we actually um so we
started with an internal data set it was
a survey that was done a few years ago
specifically around um data maturity at
byen um and so we had a data set um that
was kind of easy somewhat easy to use
and understand um and then the way we
set it up was we gave the teams um a few
weeks to uh analyze the data set in
whatever fashion or whatever type of
tool they wanted to use um and the idea
was to generate insights um there were a
few key questions that we had asked but
other than that it was pretty much open
um and then present it not in PowerPoint
so the challenge here was to not use
PowerPoint and to be creative um and so
what we did was we had a few rounds of
um of sort of battle rounds like we kind
of posed it as like a Eurovision the
voice type of you know head-to-head
knockout battle rounds where we had
groups of I think it was five or six
teams um and then they would vote for
the one team to move forward to the
finale so at the end we had I think 22
teams down to five teams so five
teams yeah four or five yeah four I know
kind of a blur up but we had it down to
five teams and so um after that we had
like the big finale where it was um
something that we did in our one of our
auditoriums and we had all the teams
come present we were actually able to
get our executive some executive
committee members to come and do some
openings and some closing and we had got
our CEO there it was a really big event
where um we then had people present in a
shark uh tank style pitch about uh the
data sets and um sort of what they would
recommend to um better um to have better
data stewardship um and different types
of strategies with data atvision and
then we crowned a winner at the end we
had some trophies and medals I love how
you're mixing All These reality shows
like the voice and Shark Tank and I um I
see Jesse asked a question in the chat I
see a star there so I'll read it but the
question was um did the competition
happen during work hours and if so how
did you pitch the idea to leadership to
get them on board I know you just
mentioned like the CEO was there for the
beginning of the competition um what did
you appeal to in order to get them to
buy into the
idea yes uh we didn't ask um you know we
uh we threw it out there we threw it out
there said you know I I saw another
question about we start with a problem
and have people solve the problem we
just threw a data set out there and said
look find some insights we left it
really broad people came back and said
how much time should I spend on this and
of course data scientists could go nuts
on something like this so we tried to
like you know look you only have three
total weeks to work on this thing um and
you have a big broad team and everything
so uh for for the question that was just
posed we didn't ask
leadership we asked people to volunteer
um and you know just kind of try to keep
it manageable I think I forget what we
said total number of hours over the
three weeks maybe around like eight I
think we was up to their discretion it's
up to their discretion some did a lot
but some did not so part of it too was I
mean there was support for this I think
you know we've been going through a lot
of changes and again there's a lot of
focus on data so part of this too was a
culture piece and I think the
recognition that this is a vital part of
you know working at a company is the the
culture and the experience so I think a
lot of that um also allowed for this to
happen and not really need permission
per se I see Ted commented about the
data governance piece being so important
and maybe this shifts a little bit away
from the data Jam but like what are some
things you've learned about data
governance through this or before yeah
this is a good one I can take this um
you know my my role here is around data
stewardship I people talk about data
governance but personally everyone hates
data governance across the board
Executives everyone but so I rebranded
it into Data stewardship which I think
evokes a little bit more of we're all in
this together and we do our own
stewardship of the of the information so
what we what we asked people to do and
I'm going to get it wrong what we asked
but we asked for like an insight and we
asked for a data stewardship
recommendation and we asked for one
other thing but I forget what that that
was now um but you know we got a lot of
stuff and then the the survey itself was
about how well does
Biogen stewarded data and how well do we
leverage data so all the questions in
the survey were about this and then the
topic was about this too um you know so
like what we heard was probably not
surprising to a lot of people but data
is hard to find it's hard to get access
to data um and then we had a lot of
great recommendations on how we could
improve that and did I miss anything I
no you you covered it pretty well but I
think in addition to that the fact that
I would say 80 to 90% of the teams which
were incredibly cross functional came to
the same conclusion which was that data
is hard defined and access and so it's
not a problem that's uh kind of isolated
to a single group it's pretty pretty um
functional cross functional which I
thought was fascinating it was expected
but it was still like very interesting
to actually see it I think part of it
too generated a lot of ideas on how to
make it better um and so that was some
of the pitches had sort of geared their
their thoughts and their pitch around
okay yeah this is what it is but these
are some of the ways that we could work
to to improve it I'd love to hear some
of those ways to improve it because I'm
sure a lot of us are facing facing that
too if that's something you can share I
know there was a lot around um kind of
metadata driven catalog in ensuring that
you know your data isn't all over the
place there was a lot of conversation
about um the fact that uh you know
copying data is something that happens
on occasion is and is obviously not best
practice so I think the big ones that we
saw were essentially a catalog to
understand what data even exists um so
that you know we know what's there and
then find a way for people who need to
access it to be able to access it so
that was a that was a big one that we
saw and the other piece really was
actually having an enterprise-wide
strategy I think that was one of the key
things that was you know identified was
just needing some sort of consistent
across Enterprise and not just specific
to each of the different individual
functions I'm trying to think back too
this was in May so it was a little bit
ago but uh I one of the ones that
resonated with me was you know not
to kind of create like a partial catalog
or something like that where as soon as
you create it it's out ofd and then ends
up being another stale data asset that
you have so really trying to way like
Danielle is saying to Enterprise it or
productional IE it and then find ways to
make sure that it's it's sustainable
long term because I feel like that's
where we where we always end up uh with
a hiccup of like how do we we could get
it going but then how do we actually you
know keep it
going
is that your team that's responsible for
Enterprise data strategy or I'm trying
to remember the name of the group
technology strategy and Innovation or is
that another no company no mine's like
the piece that I'm in charge of is the
clinical trial data but so obviously at
Biogen there's more uh data than that
but uh the Enterprise it's kind of just
across all the individual functions that
they do probably similar to what it
looks like deposit probably similar to
what it looks like at everyone else's
company yeah there was an anonymous
question that was um from a technology
perspective how did teams interact on
the data Jam did they use common
tools there was a variety um and I think
it it the randomization of teams kind of
spoke to what tools ended up being used
so for instance um I I we obviously
didn't interact with every single team
but what ended up happening was there
was a kind of data communication person
a person in charge of creating the
output a person who was more of the
programmer and then the person who was
kind of describing what the approach
would be to actually solving the problem
so it really depended on you know what
programming tools the people within that
specific team were most comfortable with
which kind of made it more exciting
because we had um people working in R
people working in SAS people working in
powerbi uh amongst others and so uh
folks did rely a lot on what we had in
house um just because it's kind of you
know sensitive data so we didn't want to
kind of put it on uh external tools but
there was still quite a variety of what
was used uh to produce the end end
results and the
solutions thank you um George I see you
had a a question in the chat just now
but maybe also one from earlier so feel
free to to ask both
there thanks um yeah I was just
wondering if you obtained any feedback
from the participants on you know the
different aspects like the Technologies
by
what especially that you know they may
not really interact with a lot you know
cross function n Danielle you want to
take that yeah so we did actually do a
post-event survey so a lot of it was
just understanding you know um thoughts
and feedback on the format uh would they
participate in something like this again
I think at the end of the day there was
a lot of really positive feedback on the
actual data jam and wanting to do it
again and there are just obviously some
logistical things that we had to deal
with that we could always make better
for next time um I think one of the
challenges was the different Geographic
locations um I think that was was tough
trying to find you know teams that were
kind of spread across when they could
actually meet because of the different
time zon so um there are a lot of things
that we we have sort of on our our list
to think about for data Jam 2.0 but um
at the end we did we did get a lot of
positive feedback and a lot of good
ideas for the next
one I don't know nja Dan anything to add
no I don't I actually don't think we got
too much feedback in the way of usage of
tools the the technology piece actually
it seemed to work pretty well depending
on what people wanted to use to
Danielle's point it was more Logistics
and then there was also feedback around
the type of data set that we could
potentially use for upcoming data jams
uh so for instance for this one we did
surveys and some people love analyzing
survey data some people despise it so
there were some there there was some
feedback there around you know what else
can we do moving forward and what data
sets could we use I think that was
another good point a lot of people had
offered like Hey we're gonna do this
again can you please use our data so
that was that was pretty cool too yeah
that's exciting now you're getting
people thinking about hey I want to use
my data for
this um I see there are a few questions
in the chat here too I think Kevin you
asked one about different uh formats
that people sure yeah yeah I like that
idea of uh of forcing them not to use
PowerPoint um because I've I definitely
find PowerPoint presentation I
definitely learned less from PowerPoint
presentations than any other format I
think that exists um but I'm curious
like what other formats people ended up
using you know instead of PowerPoint so
some people Ed the powerbi dashboards
directly and went through that others
use some forms of like canva or
animations there's one really cool group
that did sort of these animations to
tell their story um anything I know so a
lot of parbi canva
animations couple of shiny applications
oh shiny go
ahead here we um so so when you put this
question out there you never know what
you're going to get right you have to
come back it has to be a presentation
under five minutes I think yeah five
minutes it has to explain like these
three things what so what did we go to
get it kind of unbelievable I mean we
had people like dressing up in costumes
uh we had like we had people do like a
set of um like trivia
questions the cahoot and then uh we
definitely some animation like to tell
the whole
story um people walking through the
powerbi dashboard people walking through
shiny apps stuff like that but you know
some really interesting stuff and I
think people had fun with it even if
they didn't have like a big you know
epiphany of of data science in this but
they were just able to present something
because we know you need a lot of skills
for data science right and so part of
the storytelling and everything is is
part of it too getting the message
across which which formats do you think
were most effective
um I would say the funnier the
better personally for for this one um
but I think it really depends on what
you're what message you're trying to
convey I mean if you're really I think
we have some people who did some really
deep an statistical analyses and they
had shiny apps up and I think that was
really helpful to do that stuff but for
like the the big broad 300 person
audience I think you want to go big and
go uh Go creative yeah I think when we
think about the finale there were a lot
of there a few that were powerbi but
they didn't just do powerbi they had
sort of some animations or the way they
had presented it was a little bit on
more the more creative side um yeah I
like this idea
like just making it accessible to
whatever tools people wanted to use like
if they wanted to present it in canva
which is a tool I love for doing design
too um that they could use whatever
whatever they wanted
yeah and I I feel like oh sorry Dan I
was just going to say it was less
about the output like one type of output
being more effective than the other but
more so about how you communicated what
you were trying to get at what how you
communicated your story so I feel like I
saw effective presentations across all
format and I was just going to say we're
trying to make it as inclusive as
possible so it's not you know only for
PhD statisticians of which we have a lot
here um it's like really you know could
be a novice have no idea anything about
data and but you'd be maybe more
creative for the presentation side and
you could like hear from them so you
know a lot of like cross-pollination
with different people and really keeping
it open use whatever you want do
whatever you want yeah I think the teams
also really leverage there's the the
skill sets and the strengths of each
member on their team so some of people
were more heavy in the background and
some of the other people were more more
front and center in ter terms of
presentation so I think a lot of teams
use that to their advantage as
well that's really cool thanks for
thanks for sharing
that George you'd like a followup on
that kind
of yeah actually um was wondering you
know if any of those
creative uh formats have become
normalized in the culture you know
because that's it seem like such a
variety I mean I don't expect someone to
just like constantly you know dance do
an interpretive dance to their
presentations but something along the
lines of you know a little bit more
creativity and going beyond the
PowerPoint um has any of those have any
of those become like a main stake I mean
I speaking personally now when I try to
do something I think about what can I
use other than PowerPoint I don't know
if that's necessarily across the board
but it's definitely something that I
keep in mind um anytime I'm trying to
present some sort of visualization or or
insights is is trying to be a little bit
more creative yeah I think we definitely
got some feedback saying oh I'm going to
re I have to rethink about how I've been
presenting analytics results um and our
CEO is definitely anti- PowerPoint too
so uh um you know he likes idea of of
information being communicated some
other way that's more like like other
people are saying here it's more
accessible more easier to to
interpret I'm feeling bad for PowerPoint
right now some PowerPoints are beautiful
too but um I see Alan you had a question
a little bit earlier do you want to jump
in
here yeah sure um I was curious if there
were insights or things in particular
from what people produce that could be
pulled back by the the like the owners
of the data to turn into you know
anything that becomes programmatic or
insights that they can then act on um
like that obviously would be a great
outcome like hey we get 100 200 people
together and um uh it's a great engaging
activity and it's super cool if the team
that owns that data could say hey you
found a bunch of stuff or you you
started some ideas that we can
capitalize on and take forward um were
they able to take anything like that
away we let you Dan speak about
it um so I think a lot of data
jams go with this idea of like here's
this data set maybe like kaggle like
this right here's this data set figure
out this thing for me and ours wasn't
exactly like that so we didn't know
exactly what might come out of it but I
can tell you what what came out of it at
least from my perspective I know a lot
of people reached out to some of the
people who were either shiny developers
or powerbi to get consults on you know
how how to do
stuff um our CEO reached out to us and
asked you know how do we fix this whole
data problem uh that we have at at
Biogen that's he just heard for two
hours during the data Jam um and I had
one more but then I lost
it oh and the the one of the metadata C
cataloges that someone um recommended
they called it Dash I forget what it
stood
for but it was like an idea of just a
metadata catalog and that's being taken
up by our um computational biology in
research and they're going to try to
push that forward next year maybe this
isn't something you can necessarily put
a number around but have you seen that
people are working better cross
functionally because of the data Jam
uh Biogen is a big company um I think we
have about 7,000
employees uh worldwide so I don't know
that we can you really get a pure kpi on
that one um but I think you you you
definitely hear of some interactions
that never would have taken place before
and you know I think we have we run
these two community of practices which I
think are kind of like this where you
get people who are passionate about
something together you have them talk
about uh different topics we have one
around data stewardship that I run and
one about
um biog analytics and data community of
practice which they call Bad Cop Bad
which Danielle and Anuja run um but
we've definitely had more people
volunteer for leadership in there and
we've getting their voices in um to to
continue this conversation I mean I can
say too that I've gotten a lot of
feedback on oh thank you so much for
having this I was able to connect with
this person and now was able to solve
whatever issue or whatever problem or I
was able to get extra help on this so
there has been a lot of um connections
made that then help somebody in their
current role or
responsibility that's
great Okay Kevin with the hard question
in the chat do you want to jump in here
Kevin you so your CEO asked you like how
do you fix the whole data problem I'm
just curious like what did you say or
what what are you planning on getting
back to him with an answer for that
question that's a big question question
it was a big question and we were kind
of like oh okay yeah we'll uh we'll get
back to you um we thought about it for a
long time you know and I think we've
seen I'm sure you've seen I'm not sure
what organization you're in but like a
lot of these initiatives come and go and
a lot of uh hype about you know fix the
world through data or fix the entire
business through data so we talked about
this a lot uh Danielle Anuja myself Sam
and
the idea everyone wants the answer to
this on okay well the answer is it's
it's
complicated um but I I think the answer
that we really need to do is where do we
want to be as an organization with data
and we need to start from there and then
you know go down through like exactly
like how do we want to improve our
business and then try to connect our
data scientists our data innovators into
those real business decisions or B
business questions that are there so
that's the that's the my five minute
Shark Tank pitch on on what you need to
do you need to align the business you
need to get them
go say their state their position on
data because otherwise people like us we
always just like we do our initiatives
we try to do our things and it all hit
some some glass ceiling at some point
which we're we're all too familiar with
I know Danielle Anja I was just going to
say I think you know one of the things
that we had recommended and so we had
worked on putting sort of this proposal
together which uh is very you know
inclusive of what Dan was talking about
but I think the first thing was really
just actually having an Enterprise wide
data strategy goal and it's you know
something on on on as a goal for our
metrics to at least have some traction
against at that enterprise-wide level
one of the uh anonymous questions from a
little bit earlier was um what did you
think about the like follow through are
you collecting and re-sharing people's
sharings is there follow-through to hold
another event we did a couple of things
at the end to essentially make people
Solutions accessible to all of biens so
just for some context the finale
following all the battle rounds was open
invite to everyone and so we had a
number of people join from various
different departments who weren't
necessarily uh participating in the data
jam and so one thing we did was collect
links to everyone's powerbi and
dashboards and shiny applications and
kind of final findings and put them um
in an accessible location for everyone
to view and see because again because it
was a f minute Shark Tank pitch we
couldn't necessarily delve into the
details and so this gave people the
opportunity to look into how people did
the analysis and what the more detailed
findings were so that's one thing that
we did we would love to hold another
data Jam because this one has been so
successful we haven't necessarily
planned for one yet but we're hope I I
think still hoping to do one but what
has happened yeah uh what has happened
is uh I think Danielle mentioned earlier
is people have been coming to with us uh
coming to us with the data sets that
have the potential to spin off another
data jam and so we're we're kind of
playing with the idea of potentially
doing one that's a little more maybe
hardcore data science for um
specifically folks who want to dive into
the more intense data science techniques
on a specific data set and so instead of
doing a big data Jam like we did before
maybe in the interim we do a mini data
Jam of sorts and so there have been
several opportunities to to kick
something off um we just have to kind of
get together and decide what that looks
like yeah and I think you know Dan I
mentioned our community of practices
earlier so that's another Avenue that we
try to sort of keep this this going the
conversation going through we've um
we've talked a lot about like in these
data science Hangouts about data
storytelling and communication and
sometimes
like re relaying that back to having to
do your own marketing and I was
wondering if you had any like marketing
lessons learned throughout this process
too although it sounds like you're very
successful you got way more people to
sign up you thought were going to no the
uh marketing is key so Sam who's not
here uh today but uh she's our marketing
expert and I do think marketing makes a
big big difference um you know I think
when we sent out well we called it a
data JM it sounded kind of fun we had a
lot of like fun things like we had like
a logo with like a piece of jam on it
you know toast with like jam on it um I
know is my jam was the whole theme data
is my jam is the theme I know when uh we
had the finale the music was jamming by
Bob Marley we're coming in people were
walking in
um and I think when we sent it out I
know we had like one a one-page flyer to
describe this it had very little detail
you know it said like you know work with
your colleagues and we really try to say
what's in it for them like what did they
get out of it instead of like what what
are really explaining what we're doing
we're just kind of saying you know
what's in there for you get to meet your
colleagues get to work on something
interesting oh don't forget the seven
C's of jamming yeah I don't remember the
s
C's collaboration creativity
collaboration there's a bunch of C's and
the last one we just jokingly called for
the seventh C
fun we couldn't come up with a seventh
one but um yeah I think it was fun for
our team too because like all of us all
four of us love data and love getting
people together so we got really kind of
creative and crazy with the way that we
were pitching it too um and so yeah the
logo for instance we did a couple of
stickers we
had kind of Swag set up in the office as
much as we could um and tried to make it
make it fun I really like listening to
the way that the three of you all like
play off each other and like answer
these questions and go back and forth um
it it just sounds like you you did such
an amazing job with this event like
thinking of all the different parts that
make it what it is and I hope that you
get the got the recognition internally
for this event and going like above and
beyond to do that and was just curious
to learn a little bit more about what
that maybe looked like I mean I think
for one thing is our CEO joined and he
was only planning to join for 20 minutes
he ended up staying the full two hours
so that was really that was really great
and I think again there's a lot of
positive feedback afterwards um and
people are looking forward to another
one so I think that's the best you know
recognition right there yeah and I will
say for kind of the four of us we kind
of organically worked really well
together um which I don't know how that
happened but I'm glad that it did we
each took on the roles that came most
naturally to us so for instance Sam she
loves putting together graphics and she
did marketing and then you know someone
else would take on the networking piece
someone else would take on the logistics
piece and so we each just knew what our
role was within the grand team of things
and that kind of helped us to work
really well together from the start so
not a lot of conflict in the internal
team which is always good I mean we were
joking if we were like an actual team
about all the awesome things we could
get
done um so I we went heavy on the data
Jam today and diving into all parts of
that but I'm I'm curious to learn a
little bit more about some of the other
things that you're working on as well
and like the everyday kind of business
problems that you're solving too oh boy
okay um that sounded like a heavy side
you don't have to answer it's fine it's
fine it's complicated uh we a big one
that that you know my team is working on
is um reuse of clinical trial data so
clinical trial data is is personal
information obviously um but it's like
protected personal information it's very
very valuable right I mean we know you
know we study diseases that don't have
cures we study diseases that don't have
medicines um we're trying to find better
ways to to treat the disease trying to
find better ways to measure the disease
and that's all you know held together in
this clinical trial data that we run um
so a big thing that I'm working on right
now is how do we best leverage this um
it is immensely complicated uh there's
um many many privacy regulations many um
you know gcp good clinical practice um
regulations around this but I I have
this feeling that we need to find a way
to use the data up to its maximum
potential or maximum allowability and no
further but if we
don't if we just say hey it's
complicated I'm not touching that I I
feel like we're like losing a big piece
of of of medicinal development um so
that's a big piece that I'm working on I
know n is helping me on that um see what
they have to say what they're working on
I'm sure it's different so for me spefic
oh you want to go no go for it samiel so
for me specifically um a lot of why what
I do is really focused on understanding
sort of um the business risk for some of
our portfolio and programs so really
understanding so what our portfolio
looks like what are the decisions that
we're trying to make to whether we
progress programs or we terminate
programs um so a lot of it has to do
with really modeling and understanding
um our current portfolio the different
decision points the investment points
what's the risk what's the value um and
ultimately coming up with um insights
for leadership to then decide leadership
and our governance then decide you know
what we what our portfolio should look
like um what are the programs what are
the things that we invest in uh but
again a lot of this is balancing um the
business risk with a scientific risk um
so lots of different more like I'm
focused a lot more on the operational
data um than more than anything but a
lot of it is you know balancing out
those different risks and um really
helping decision makers understand what
what the options are so I've been lucky
enough to kind of work with several
different uh folks within analytics and
data Sciences so I am helping Dan with
part of his um secondary use project but
I think my biggest project is around
automation
for our endtoend clinical reporting and
analytics space and so I help to manage
but also contribute to the strategy of
understanding you know what can be
automated and also what should be
automated because there's a lot that can
be automated but we want to make sure
that you know the resourcing that we put
into it is worth um the impact that it
will eventually drive and so part of
that is you know playing with the fact
that you know people work in SAS but how
do we bring in additional languages how
do we bring in more um additional
analytics techniques when is it worth
doing that and what is the best way
logistically to also bring that in so it
it started off as like a smaller scope
of work but it's kind of ballooned out
to be this you know massive initiative
that has been very fun to work on so
thank you all for for sharing really
interesting I um I wanted to remind
everybody with 10 minutes left here that
if I missed any questions from anybody
in the chat among conversation feel free
to just repost it there or raise your
hand here too but I know Bill loves this
question and we have to ask it too but
was there any application of AI or chat
GPT or large language models in this um
I can take that so
uh we got a lot of questions of can I
take this data and copy and paste it
into Chad GPT which the answer is no
just FYI if you work going to become
that answer is no but we have an
internal instance of of chat GPT that's
secure um and people did use that um we
had comments so I think I forget how
many people took the survey 300
something um and people wrote comments
in there and so people were doing like
sentiment analysis of the the comments
and trying to pick out some insights
that were in the comments which was fun
thank you um Anda I really like that
point you just brought up about like we
talk about automation a lot but when is
it worth doing going through the process
of doing the automation using resources
to do that and I I'm curious like how do
you figure that out I mean that's tough
right because you have an initial um
estimate of yeah I'll be able to um
develop the the macros or the scripts
needed to be able to automate this in x
amount of time but then there's other
pieces that we need to factor in around
you know how long is it going to take to
adopt how long is it going to take to
scale um and then there's a learning
curve associated with it as well so it
is that something we've been as as more
people become aware of the automation
initiative it's automatically leading to
more ideas flowing in and so we're
really having to put a structure in
place to try and gauge from the very
beginning how much resourcing is going
to be used in order to make this and so
I know that doesn't really answer your
question but but that's because you know
it's it's tough to gauge right from the
very beginning uh how much resourcing is
going to be put
in um but we we do try
to account for both you know development
in addition to change management in
addition to adoption and set kind of
tangible and achievable targets
intermittently I was going to say queue
up the xkcd but I see someone I saw
someone put that in I was like it's got
to be the one I think it is
that's a good one for us to all take I
remember that one and I didn't know
where to find
it um Nessa I see you had a follow-up
question from the previous question you
want to jump in here yeah um I just
wanted to ask about the internal
instance of chat GPT you're dealing with
because well I've been talking to a
bunch of farm companies I'm really
interested in in um how people are doing
this is it a web chat tool if for goey
like most people access chat GPT in the
real world or is it um all API
based and also is it accessible to
people who are not data scientists like
can a a chemist access this really
easily I don't know much about it I feel
like when I saw it it was command line
so I would not call that a gooey um but
I I think it's like a private Azure
instance of the of the GPT but I I I
don't know too much but no I don't think
we don't have like
a chat GPT for Biogen where it's like
friendly user interface and ask it any
question we don't have that yet
see yeah thank you all for the great
questions I see Alan you had a follow-up
question around more of the like broader
community events want to jump in yeah
I'm just curious if there are other kind
of things that connect you know into
like a single sort of community of
practice um for you know folks who
participated in the jam but also more
more broadly do you have other events um
is there other kind of conscientious
organizing going on um just curious what
that what that looks like to to kind of
keep these folks seeing one another and
potentially connecting um you know
beyond beyond that event yeah I can
speak for the community of practice that
we run so we try to have forums um well
we were trying to have it you know at
least every other month and um so
there's a series that we have called
datab bites and basically what it is is
either bringing somebody from it or
somebody from the community to talk
about the work that they're doing um and
or more recently we had one that was um
actually somebody that participated in
data jam and wanted to leverage the data
Jam Network to look at their data and
help generate insights um and I know
we've also talked about um doing some
more um Collective uh meetings across
the different communities so kind of
gathering all the different communities
together
on a more regular basis because did
bring a lot of those communities
together um and so there are definitely
plans to start to to continue that it's
been a little bit hectic at buen lately
so we haven't been able to do as much as
we wanted to but I think um now that
things are somewhat settling um we are
definitely looking at sort of the next
few key um events cool thanks I hope
those are are successful sounds like a
good a really good foundation bill I see
you had a question around their
environment you want to jump in
and it the question was um around
different Cloud providers are you heavy
into Azure or aw AWS one over the other
or do you have mostly on Prem data
versus
cloud and as always no worries if these
are certain questions that you can't
answer
too I'm pretty sure have a little bit of
everything it's a good
answer double check here to see if the
any questions that we
missed um something I I was curious
about when you were talking about the
different community events and people
who maybe are like new to data science
as well uh what does the training look
like for your team so if somebody maybe
I guess ju I guess there's two factors
here like onboarding for someone who
comes in with data science experience or
analytics experience versus also
somebody who maybe hadn't used data in
science before but wants to maybe
Danielle uh like a lot of it really is
on the job training um so it's really
just once you you know working with the
team working with your manager um but at
the same time too I know for some of
what we hire for we try to sort of be a
little bit diverse so a lot of times
there are some technical aspects that we
are looking for but a lot of the times
for anything really data related in in
my world I look for people that are just
genuinely curious and want to solve
problems
so I feel like um as long as you have
those two skills and that you're willing
to learn that's pretty much how we get
things done I don't know Dan in your
space if it's any different but that's
at least how I sort of handle things
over here yeah I think in the in the
data science groups we hire a lot of
more senior people there's not like a
lot of entry level roles there but I
think maybe you're also hinting at like
a although I hate the word a data
literacy uh kind of eort of how do you
how does every single person in the
entire organization know not to present
a pie chart um you know and stuff like
that and that's something that we we
need to look at and I think these
Community practices that we have are the
best way that we could really do it it's
organic it's you know leaning on people
already wanting to learn and then like
kind of helping them get up to the next
level with what they already want to
learn I know kind of speaking to the uh
communities of practice but there are
some like ours are a little more General
but there are specialized ones so
there's a machine learning group um that
that dives into that a little bit more
and we're about to start a data science
conference uh which will bring in kind
of speakers and and the such for for
people to um learn a little bit more
there thank you so much um I feel like I
just have to say this because biogen's
in Boston but I run the Boston usar
group with my co-host Kevin
and if anybody from the team would be
interested in joining us I just shared
the link to our event um in the chat but
we have a series of lightning talks
coming up and it'd be cool to do some
events with some others from Biogen
too uh let me double check here on any
questions we miss if anybody in the last
minute here wants to raise your hand
feel free well thank you all so much for
joining it's it's really awesome to hear
how well the the data Jam went and how
many people were interested in the event
too that there's been a number of people
who have reached out to me around
holding their own sort of data
competitions and I'm so excited to be
able to share this as a resource with
them too thank you so much for having us
this was fun thanks Rachel this is great
you if anyone has any questions please
feel free to reach out you can find us
uh through through this or on LinkedIn
for sure wonderful thank you all so much
have a great rest of the day thank by
thanks